we have some new tour dates and these
are some new ones Memphis Tennessee
we've added a show August 4th and 5th at
the cannon Center for the Performing
Arts
um I know the Chattanooga show sold out
don't worry don't go get a fancy price
ticket we will come back
um and you'll have another opportunity
Toronto Ontario uh August 30th and 8th
show added in Toronto San Jose
California we've added a second show
September 14th
uh and 13th Oakland California
September 16th at the Paramount Akron
Ohio we've added a show
um on the 8th or 7th Washington D.C
we've added a show October 19th and 20th
if your city is sold out just keep an
eye out we'll come back through we also
have some tickets left for Windsor
Ontario on August 18th get your tickets
through theovan.com
t-o-u-r and thank you so much for coming
out and supporting the return of the Rat
tour
today's guest has a new special coming
out on Netflix next week you'll want to
get a hold of that
um
it's he's unbelievable the specialist
called Soup To Nuts he's one of a kind
uh he has two of his own podcasts called
we might be drunk and Tuesdays with
stories
um
he's from New Orleans he's a Louisiana
boy like myself I'm always in awe of his
talent and I'm grateful to spend time
with him today today's guest is Mr Mark
Norman
shine
sit and tell you possible
[Music]
[Applause]
let's make it this guy I mean you've
been through a lot we both do we made it
yeah hell yeah you were in Edmonton Sin
City baby yeah the ah
there was smoke in the air they had some
wild fires going on and the go uh the
governor said that they had to cancel
the show on fra on Friday oh damn so we
had to cancel and stay an extra day was
it all brown up there in the sky like
Trudeau's face he was uh Indian or
something yeah that's true he was a uh
like one of those lamp buddies I think
he was like Aladdin I don't know and
that's not a racial term I don't know
what the lamp Buddy's good ah it's
magical which I don't even think is
Indian
maybe I got that what is that Middle
Eastern
Alibaba I'm not sure I think dude it
would be awesome if you could actually
rub on any on a woman and yeah he always
got it yeah that's fun
if you could rub on an Indian person and
they had to do something for you
then to Grant a wish that would be nice
they also have to face Mecca when they
piss or something oh wow maybe that's
not India a couple ignorant honkies here
yeah welcome to ignorant honky dude
ignorant honkies in the morning
welcome to ignorant hoagies in the
morning we're out here we're live bro we
just got through like some bat I feel
like you're like a battered spouse
you've been up all night um Road hard
and put away wet yeah we stayed up all
night it was the last night of the fully
loaded tour slip and slide all day
drinking all day giant Amphitheater at
the Gorge 15 000 people
drink it I did some shrooms I'm gay we
did it up
oh definitely if you don't end gay at
the end then you're out if you're on
drugs and you go gay I think you're good
yeah it was just a thing I just tried it
oh yeah man that cocaine gets a little
gay at the bottom of the bag that's true
especially with this [__] yeah
nothing gayer than that move oh the last
two balls of an eight ball are on
another dude usually
eight balls that's four Dudes that's a
lot bro yeah gay dudes name that
appropriately man uh yeah dude I saw the
videos that looked magical I saw I don't
know if it was bird or use someone put
up a video of like you guys waking
people up and just showing them where
you were at on the bus like when you got
up in the morning yeah yeah well the bus
gets quick as you drink all night on the
bus because you're just sitting there
and then I had uh one last year was me
Shane Gillis Joey Diaz big J and Bert it
was like a sleep apnea convention and
Joey's like [__] sucker [__]
that's how he sleeps with a feather
going up down oh yeah dude his CPAP
machine one time I saw had a bowl of
weed built in and I'm like I don't think
that's
ah that'd be a hell of a bong though huh
yeah that's one way to do it dude yeah
yeah it goes right to the the lungs
but yeah fun time it was magical the Sun
is setting you ever been to the gorge no
I never been able to sell 15 000 tickets
wow that's Bert you know but it's such
an event in this catering and beer
trucks and slip inside there's all these
events and activities and uh
it's incredible oh
that's one vote for Trump right there
um well you can see we're in a boom like
you look out in this audience like oh we
are in a comedy boom we're right in the
eye of the storm here dude it really is
I mean people want to come out what do
you think that is why do you think it's
at such a like a wild time where people
want to come out and I have a couple
theories and then I want to talk to you
if you like it this way or if you liked
it more when it was a niche art form in
a basement so that was kind of romantic
but I think comedy is huge right now
because a the internet you can just
before you had a Comedy Central and an
HBO hour that was it really or some
albums so just so much and we got used
to it and HR is up up everybody's ass so
when you come out there and start
queefing it feels good
right right so that yeah these people
haven't heard a good queef they haven't
heard a queef through a mic they haven't
heard somebody pop off they haven't they
haven't heard any risk yes exactly and
people like that risk they live for it I
used to go dark at shows and they'd be
like Jesus Christ now I go dark and
they're like yeah shoot into my face
yeah
yeah my daughter's [__] a black guy
somebody yelled at one of my shows
really yeah and everybody and people
were like oh all right man I think yeah
there's sometimes people just coming to
get something off of their chest yeah
for sure because he's been thinking
about that but he can't say that at the
FedEx plant he works at uh
was he happy or was he like uh I think
it was kind of like he kind of it was
like halfway fist in the air uh not a
full white power yeah yeah that's like a
little yeah like a mixed power a mixed
power yeah it's kind of true because
it's like that's white power this is
black power yeah that's true there's not
much I mean not much in the middle yeah
so if you just raise your hand and ask
her like if you're just a mixed guy you
just kind of curious right yeah
that's an array interracial power yeah
okay it's the the worst Captain Planet
episode
foreign
dude yeah that looks magical for you
guys right I was like I was real I was
really jealous in a way I mean I mean I
was just like wow this is unbelievable
it is what's it like getting to be
because I always I'm just by myself
usually you know I I'll have like
already Madness I'll have like
um Laura Peak oh good eggs or Maddie
Smith yeah funny folks but it's not like
getting out there with such a group yeah
does it feel more pressure does it like
does it get competitive when there's
that many folks on the lineup a little
bit and then you just want to kill and
you don't want to be the one to [__] it
up but it's also nice to hang with
Comics because you know we're getting
more successful so you just start
potting and then you do your tour and
then you sit in your apartment or your
house for a week and uh this is like all
day I've got Santino over here and uh uh
you know David tell over there and it's
just fun and it's good to be with Comics
again
it's just it's like summer camp with
booze damn
and you guys do a lot of events on
Bert's tour it seemed like I saw
somebody eating an uncrustable
oh that I missed that one I don't know
if that was that's an event
I don't know a couple of it was a couple
of kind of fat like I don't want to say
a couple thicker guys eating like I
don't think we're sharing one is that is
that what is that the PB and J yeah oh
those are good it was stavaros oh yeah
he was there he was there yeah man it's
a good crew they hand-picked the right
people but those Uncrustables you gotta
watch out I mean I think that killed
Ralphie May I wouldn't be surprised and
this is the town that he died in man is
that right yeah oh [__] Rafi used to
live like less than a mile from here
whoa oh
oh damn this is a shampoo around here
Sea World
sorry that's it he's he's dead R.I.P mix
power
mixed power dude well I was open the
whole time ah
dude yeah man you um
you've been doing I mean you just keep
doing better man I gotta say your new
special I'm gonna think he's all just to
tell you dude it's so funny man I can't
believe you watched it I appreciate it
dude it is
it made me like
I mean you're just I think you're one of
the best joke writers that there is and
it's just so many jokes non-stop so even
if you hate your date that you're
watching it with there's more humor
coming right right like you don't have
to lean over and even check in with him
or her right you know like I can this
guy has me from the beginning to the end
hey I appreciate it I worked hard on it
and uh I can't have silence so I gotta
keep putting punch lines in some of
these Comics go out there they're
sitting on a stool they're cool as a
cucumber I gotta keep singing yeah all
right pan and I think I'm I'm kind of a
boring guy do you ever feel like that
like I feel like when I go on stage
everybody's like all right we can pee
now because I'm like uh I'm regular
looking I'm not I'm not the fat guy or
the gay guy yeah so I feel like I'm
boring them so I got a really machine
gun it wow that's interesting yeah you
wonder sometimes why I got like why well
first of all the silence thing I can
totally relate to yeah it's like if
there was silence
I always am like okay how long am I safe
in this silence yes exactly but there's
two kinds of Silence there's the [__]
I'm freaking out sounds and then there's
that like let me hold you guys in the
palm of my hand silence and then yeah
you'll hit you with a big tension
breaker yeah and I can't do either
I suck at silence I think it's a
parental my parents they do a thing
where they don't they don't respond to
you you ever have this you know like uh
my mom will be like so what'd you do
yesterday how was your flight oh it was
crazy terrorists came on the plane and
they put guns on the Pilot's head and I
beat one of them up and they're like
well it's unseasonably hot huh and
you're like come on nothing on the
terrorist thing
yeah why yeah do you think that's it
like does it come from like when we were
kids like why is it that commit that oh
some of us some of us work with the
silence better like Dave Chappelle loves
silence yeah like he'll backstroke in
the silence he'll have a couple
cigarettes while things are quiet
um
you know some like uh Anthony jeselnick
knows that I mean he's a master of solo
he's great yeah he's a [__] he's like a
like Hans Zimmer of Silence you know yes
the Zim but why do yeah why is it yeah
if things got silent like I even noticed
it if I'm like dating someone or
something like yes oh that's scary and
things are [__] quiet I think I don't
know how they're feeling yes exactly and
it's like I can't stand to not know how
somebody is feeling yeah you got to give
me feedback that's what's so great about
comedy you say a thing they laugh you
say a thing and laugh there's a a back
and forth but some people give you
nothing yeah you ever have an Uber
driver and and he's he's trying to chat
with you so you're like all right I'll
chat and then you start talking and he
gives you nothing back that's that's my
superpower is I can say something and
have no one respond like at a party oh
damn what a horrible it's a horrible
power I'm the worst Avenger
but uh you're just talking and people
just kind of just peel off yeah yeah I
think I say weird [__] you know
especially around normal people like
non-comedians you know like what's up
with the black people not be able to
swim and they're like all right we gotta
get out of here the meter's running or
whatever
and I'm not trying to Pro you know say
crazy [__] I'm just saying what I think
oh yeah I think saying something I would
say things like around my big thing was
if I was around like a buddy and their
family and stuff I would spill an insane
secret about my buddy and in front of
his parents in order to create any sort
of environment that didn't that I could
watch yes and not have to be like the
the person that had the major like
um like didn't have like a real
partnership in that exchange right right
and you get to watch it now they're
going no Mom that's not true and she's
like well you told me this and now
you're you're eating popcorn yeah God I
loved that that is you know what else is
nice I'm um I have two friends mutual
friends who are fighting and I'm in the
middle
I love being in the middle of two
friends fighting because they both keep
coming to me can you believe he said
this can you believe he said that blah
blah I'm like I know I know and I love
it because I'm off the hook yeah but I
get to be the good guy help both friends
and they hate each other yeah it's a
blast
dude it is fun when friends are fighting
it's like you feel like you have
something to do yes yes exactly and
they're they're so into it they're like
[__] this guy out I'm like I know he
sucks then the other guy's like I know
he's the worst I'm like oh it's so bad
and is that burden uh Joe oh geez
boy you're good what are you is that
Nancy Drew over here no why are uh Ari
uh Ari shafir was talking about it yeah
yeah I don't know if uh they want us to
bring it up oh okay I didn't know that I
thought it was uh arya'll bring anything
he'll put something in your drink for
Christ's sake
put that story in Bert's drink
Arya I think you could bring up the look
of back on Ari's face just now even
looking at this look at this yeah this
is him he's a little Jewish Troublemaker
but this is the perfect look of a face
as somebody's like hey look at this I'm
about to show you this yeah uncomfort
between these other two people you know
you know you said you like to throw it
at the the mom and your friend that's
what he does but on a huge platform yeah
he does he did it with the Kobe thing he
likes the big the drama yeah he likes
that big [__] bomb he does he loves
he loves it and I I get it to a point
because we're all nervous about people
not liking us or whatever so if you just
go in all the way and give him a reason
not to like you instead of just them not
liking you genuinely are they are you
wondering if they don't like it yes but
if you're like hey just don't like me
exactly now you kind of have control of
it yeah interesting yeah dude this uh
this strike came up Isn't it nice to not
have to worry about that yeah I feel for
them I hope they get the I think they'll
I think it'll come around the SAG after
strike yeah right here negotiations
cratered over AI streaming Revenue
sharing
pay hikes and more can you get to that
article just a little bit that's tough I
did like what Fran Drescher said I
thought it was pretty cool to see her
vid the no The Nanny yeah I used to have
a crush on her oh who didn't dude
it's a weird choice that she's the head
of this how did it become her well the
funny thing was a lot of people didn't
know right yeah because like I've always
you get the things in the mailbox I just
like vote for this person you know and I
always try to vote for like
the crate you know I vote for like the
wildest person to put in there because
sometimes they're on there right you
know it's like Wendy Williams yeah Kanye
yeah yeah or Robert FK Jr yeah yeah
let's put some money in here yeah it was
really gonna make something happen yeah
let's shake it up yeah or even that
little they had a little person that was
on like a um
a soap opera
um and he was always getting attacked by
cats you know on there what yeah and I
tried to vote him in a couple years
um which what soap opera was that Google
soap opera little person I gotta see
this oh this guy was beautiful man
really yeah I think I even did it I even
donated to a GoFundMe for him oh damn
that's him right there well that's not
that's a kid passions that was him you
sure that's not just a child I mean or
is that a [__] I mean I take you call
Josh Ryan Evans that was him God man
that's a scary looking beautiful he
looks like uh Kim Zolciak Kim Zolciak or
in the face looks like Corey biermann's
wife okay
oh is he Willow no I think Willow might
have been his father oh big shoes well
small shoes to fill
but yeah yeah but he definitely uh oh he
was on passions and he um
and yeah he was just God he was so
beautiful and I remember
there's this famous episode because I
saw two uh I saw a little person
fighting two cats one time at a um wow
is that pay-per-view No it should have
been yeah
it was unsanctioned and there was um it
was down in hermose I was going down
there like a beach event or something
about walking and there's a little
person I mean battling two cats and
you're in like a carport oh my God what
a sight and other people and he like
looked over to help and I'm like I don't
even know whose side I'm on right yeah
what'd you do to the cats you know I
gotta hear their side yeah and a lot of
people don't believe in little people
that you know they're like this is you
know
we gotta stop that you know there's all
types of kind of unique theories out
there but yeah I and I used to tell it
and then I told a story about it on
stage for a while but
um but anyway yeah this I remember that
guy and
um deep cut you know what the tough you
know we're all friends with Brad
Williams and uh oh yeah met we man once
the old the puffy hands are what throws
me every time yeah and I don't know and
you know what I feel bad I don't know
sometimes when I shake a hand of a
little person I don't know if I should
go down and kind of get you know because
you want to give him like a hug like you
do everybody else a little half hug
right but then I don't know if me going
down to like uh coming down more to
their height is um makes them upset or
something I I wonder the same thing I
just pick them up and zerbert them oh
yeah that's what I do just to knock it
out oh like Biden did with that girl do
you see that oh my God he likes to sniff
those gal's hair oh yeah he likes knit
he [__] nibbled on that one little um
it was a little wider a it was like a
delicacy I think for him bring that one
up can you see that can you get on
Twitter and find some of these he's like
a vampire that's how he gets his energy
oh he's smelling kids yeah and he goes
oh
he really put it on that kid there was
that wild videos
I mean sniffing all those kids how old
are you yeah yeah that was a crazy
Montage he should sniff a little boy
just to even it out yeah it's true
especially gay rights people should be
like hey sniff a boy right right or
sniff you know sniff a I'd love to see
him Huff on a couple darker children yes
yeah it'd be nice to be honest and hit
some animals too like mix it up so maybe
people just think that's your thing yeah
or catch I'd love to see him catch a
little bit of dander off of a off of a
you know
yeah some type of a pet or even a middle
eastern child yeah now we're talking you
know get a hit or something that's
really gonna [__] you know oh you
catch a little bit of cardamom off of
Bangladeshi kid that'll keep you up for
two days man and he's out here riding
these white kids the easy prey too yeah
come on too easy I mean how weird it is
really strange right it's very odd yeah
he's like the drunk friend at the bar
he's slurring words he keeps falling and
then he's freaking out the gals
and do you I feel like the media just
pretends like he's okay do you feel that
at all of course of course yeah it's so
obvious that they're clearly uh they
know they just don't wanna they can't
say that's what sucks about the media
like
it's so biased just tell me what
happened yeah it's so annoying like you
know Fox knew if it's a if it's a white
shooter Fox News won't really cover it
but CNN will but if it's a black shooter
CNN won't cover it but Fox will it's
very strange
yeah it is it's like yeah definitely I
think it's another reason why people
want to go and see
speakers I mean not only comedians are
are selling out or having a lot of big
crowds but
um speakers are I mean guys like Jordan
Peterson true
um Lex Friedman people love listening oh
yeah well I have a theory that uh things
are so wishy-washy like gender is very
fluid and this and that nobody can tell
you what's what so when some guy comes
out in a suit like an autistic Lex
Friedman they're like this is how it is
you're like all right thank you I just
needed I need some facts here yeah
enough with the feelings and my truth
what the hell is my truth
everybody's got a truth yeah OJ had a
truth yeah you know that's true dude so
like yeah he was selling Cutco and [__]
just went awry
damn that's a bad sale when the head
heads comes off I've read that somewhere
that somebody said he was just selling
Cutco and things went awry damn dude did
you see speaking of that did you see the
kid that uh they just had a Young Man
Who Lost His Head
uh can you bring this story up whoa lost
his head yeah he lost his head and they
put his head back on what
what yeah man AI is getting good yeah
yeah holy [__]
do you ever see the old the it's not a
video but a kid was born with a giant
dong and they had to they had to uh what
do you call it reduct reduce it um yeah
so he had this huge football shaped dong
and his dad said this is you got to get
rid of this but still make it a big dong
so they gave him an eight incher yeah
they got to bring it back down to eight
oh wow that's great I know I always had
a law I had a uh adult penis when I was
a child really yeah whoa so it was very
I don't want to say it was challenging
you know nobody likes to say that
you know sure it's like you know it's
not like a ball and chain but it's
definitely like you have to monitor how
you kind of move you know whoa so like
you'd have a diaper with like a just a
mushroom head coming out the side yeah
you couldn't fit
wow yeah I mean I remember they'd have
to get like the fat like the they had a
different name for them but like kind of
the fatty kid diapers and they had to
um I remember
having to sleep on my back or have like
even like a little pillow put up against
my mother said
they would take a roll of my dad's socks
and put it up next to my body while I
slept and they would set my wiener on It
come on that crazy damn because they
didn't want it to like pull my spine
over a different direction or something
I was very young that's a heavy dong
yeah it was uh you know when that song
Swing Low Sweet charity oh yeah but you
grew into it yeah yeah you grow into it
you know it happens sometimes I'm not
sure what it's called when you have a
adult body part when when you're young
yeah you have to prepare for your
financial future there's no doubt about
it you have to prepare
for what you want your future to look
like if you want to save
you need to save
I'll tell you this a credit card
consolidation loan from lightstream can
help you pay off your credit cards and
lock in a low fixed interest rate
start at 8.99 APR with auto pay and
excellent credit
now I'll say this I've had some loans
that I Consolidated and worked out great
so I'm familiar with this process
from light stream you can get a loan
from five thousand to one hundred
thousand and there are absolutely no
fees
you can even get your money as soon as
the day you apply
and just for our listeners apply now to
get a special interest rate discount
and save even more the only way to get
this discount is to go to
lightstream.com
t-h-e-o that's l-i-g-h-t
s-t-r-e-a-m.com slash Theo
subjects credit approval rates range
from 8.99 APR to 25.49 APR and include
point five zero percent auto pay
discount lowest rate requires excellent
credit terms and conditions apply and
offers are subject to change without
notice visit
lightstream.com
Theo for more information have you been
in an accident have you been damaged up
check your body is something broken is
something missing that's the you're like
whoa jeepers
no wonder I'm late to work I don't have
a limb
well Morgan and Morgan is America's
largest injury Law Firm
if someone has done you wrong
well what are you gonna do
being fair is
very important to me Morgan and Morgan
they have over 100 offices Nationwide
and more than 800 lawyers
with over 15 billion dollars recovered
for clients Morgan and Morgan has a
proven track record of fighting to get
you full and fair compensation
submitting a claim to Morgan and Morgan
is as easy as as washing your thighs
baby warm water and good soap Free Soap
if you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan
that's right it could be a car accident
could have been something happened at
work
fairness is important
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless they win for more information go
to forthepeople.com this past weekend or
dial pound law pound 529 from your cell
phone that's
forthepeople.com slash this past weekend
or dial pound law pound 529 from
yourself this is a paid advertisement
did we get that Fran Drescher video
oh here we go frankly
how far
how they
poverty that they're losing money left
and right when giving hundreds of
millions of dollars to their CEOs
it is disgusting shame on them
they stand on the wrong side of history
at this very moment
we stand in solidarity
in unprecedented Unity
our Union and our sister unions and the
unions around the world
are standing by us
as well as other labor unions that's
good
that's interesting huh I mean I feel
like she really kind of I feel like she
you definitely feel what she's saying
yeah yeah they got millions and they
can't give the right or some I know
the residuals thing is a bummer
well I think in a lot of it goes back to
just the history of people not getting
residuals you know it's like all those
years of people on shows and you hear
that they don't have they didn't make
any money from you know like you hear
that a lot about the cast from like
Saved by the Bell and stuff like that
like they were on those hit shows right
and they didn't that it just wasn't part
of their deals I know so I think a lot
of you have that old energy that's built
up so she went through all that right
um the problem is on Twitter you have so
many people that come out against her
and are like oh here's a millionaire you
know trying to say what uh what the
regular person wants and it's like but
still somebody has to
um
somebody has to speak up you know yeah
yeah and I think they'll be fine but
that sucks to be a writer and just like
ah We're Not Gonna We're not gonna pay
you well also because a lot of the
writers they work on spec you know they
do a project first and bring It Forward
oh yeah so I think when you partner in
the fact they're doing all of that work
yeah and then which some of those things
never lead to anywhere true how many
friends do we have that have probably
written five scripts but I've written
three scripts I've written a million
packets SNL whatever TV show yeah and
they just steal your jokes yes hey
here's my jokes like you never hear back
I know you actually have to sign a thing
when you turn in a packet that says hey
this is not yours anymore you send it to
us and you're like that's that's my best
sketch I need that let me shoot it if
you're not gonna hire me it's on it
really is man it's such a um it's a it's
a sick business and there's never any
accountability you don't know once you
send that packet off what happens yeah
and then now you have all these yeah you
have a lot of actors and I guess they're
um they're worried about AI which makes
sense you know they're worried about all
of that ai's getting good man I uh
people send me jokes that they put in AI
in my voice and I'm like that's pretty
good that's better than anything I ever
had
also I'm a robotic guy who tells jokes
wow now ai's taking my [__] it's a good
point huh yeah scary but I think maybe
that's also one of the reasons why
people want to come see something that's
real
I want to come see a human I want to I'm
sick of talking to a robot when I need
my plane ticket fixed I'm sick of
not being able to say anything at work
everything is like like goes into like
um like what the Rules of Civility are
and stuff that work and I want to be
able to come out and [__] you know
hear somebody possibly dropping in bomb
yes yes and like little things you go
unhoused that's what we call homeless
people now so you're at work or you're
in the shower going unhoused what the
[__] is that but you can't say anything
at work so then you go see the you go to
the Chuckle Hut and you see the guy talk
about unhoused what's that about bro you
go ah I needed that yes so your special
did you feel like you had to get it out
that's what I thought when I was
watching I'm like Mark's so prolific
that he's just gotta get this out no I'm
not one of those guys I can sit on an
hour for a while and just keep honing I
think jokes are better when you they
marinate over you over a long period of
time I think people put stuff out too
quick yeah you know I think Louie [__]
that up with the hour a year thing oh
remember when that pressure came up oh
that was new you got Jay Leno going I'm
doing the something about Reagan you
know know so that that [__] everybody
up and it kind of made it this weird the
new standard I'm like well that was just
him doing that yeah but now we got to do
it
yeah that was a lot of pressure yeah but
I think people just I think you're right
that's why this is even popular talking
all we're doing is talking having a
conversation which we used to do all the
time and that kind of even went away oh
that's true huh people don't get
together yeah like when do you
yeah some of the biggest conversations
now are when you hear people talking
with like some lost kid that came with a
ring doorbell cam yeah ring doorbell
ruin the Jehovah Witness yeah by the way
but but yeah like even this weekend you
know when you're hanging out with a guy
you kind of know you know him but you're
not like hanging out every day and
there's that weird moment of awkwardness
everything in my body's going ah get out
of here look at your phone uh put your
headphones in yeah do something but if
you just get over that it's a blast but
we don't want to get over that because
Comfort everything is so comfortable now
oh yeah there's definitely that moment
like it's like when you're on a diet and
they come down to the aisle of the plane
with the cookies or something or a snack
or whatever you know do you want a
little cookie all you have to do if you
just get past that thing of no I'ma
stick to whatever my little plan is yeah
yeah because there's so we've yeah we've
become this like immediate fix yes and
the phone's easiest one easy one
millisecond of discomfort you're like oh
Instagram yeah not good because it's
hard to get back out of that it's hard
to get back to normal once you're
addicted like that do you ever look up
from your phone and you don't even know
kind of where you're there's like a half
a second where you're like I don't where
am I am I married
I have that while driving I'm like I
just wrote to 10 people and I've changed
States twice I didn't even realize it
yeah dude that's so yeah there's
something yeah that's true these are
like just people talking wow that's it
we're just having a conversation which
was
people crave it I create I listen to
like five pods a day yeah I love it but
I think just generations and years and
years of like DNA of hanging out talking
in a circle in the woods or in a castle
or whatever the hell and then uh we just
stopped doing it yeah
dude imagine meeting somebody just like
on a roadway back like
like um I was out in Utah recently and I
was like dude it is desolate out here oh
yeah and it's so hot like I couldn't
imagine having been like a Pioneer you
know yeah I think about that all the
time traveling across the way you have a
horse yeah one of your kids is sick one
of your kids is about to die yeah they
got the cholera yeah and you don't want
to say it you still want to play with
them and wake him up in the morning sure
you know even though God's Not Gonna
wake him up one of these days you know
and I hate to say that but it's like
every you know and we even went to like
little graveyards in some of the every
half the graves were like four years old
seven years old brutal nothing worse
than a little coffin oh yeah so tiny
yeah but I think it's I think by that
all the time those old guys who would
get on a wagon and then like half their
family would die before they got there
and they just had to keep going I had to
deal with it Grandpa's dead keep going
yeah and it's just St Louis when they
get there
right right I know that sucks it's worth
Grandpa yeah you know
and there was nothing in sale there
wasn't even an arch no yeah there wasn't
anything no Dairy Queen nothing
yeah I I and I wonder if you met
somebody back then like
um all the things you'd have to like if
you met somebody on the trail you had to
kind of really decipher like is this
person a good person you had a you were
really keen on like body language and
awareness so like every second of a
conversation had a lot of like value to
it you had to know if that if you could
share a campfire because if at night
they were gonna try to rape your wife or
husband exactly I mean think about the
Native Americans you see those [__]
pull up on a horse with the feathers and
the face paint
oh my God yeah we're in a Chuck E cheese
yeah I was like come in St Louis what
the [__] but yeah no that's uh scary
[__] and those guys were
tough yeah I couldn't I don't think I
could have done it but I think the value
of a conversation back then it was like
it was like that's where you got all
your news from to some guy on a trail
yes
crazy
and that wasn't even there was no paper
no I mean there was paper but he didn't
have like a extra extra he read all
about it you know yeah he just had to go
hey you know uh
whatever the hell is the president now
and you're like oh [__] I don't even
know that yeah yeah
yes yeah yeah they'd be like Thurman's
in or something yeah like my God that
guy I didn't vote for him whatever three
cheers open up a can of beans huh yeah a
lot of beans back then God
yeah it's just uh
yeah the Val yeah how a conversation has
like changed over the years and yeah now
it's like we're like this little museum
for conversations like yeah sometimes I
think like
all human things will just be in a
museum like one day like aliens will
take their children to like see like a
smile whoa wow this was something that
people as if they had Joy their face
would turn up at the corners of their
mouth whoa that's crazy good call you
know what's you know I was thinking
about this the other day well hi
if an animal shows you his teeth you're
in trouble he's like but if we show
teeth it's like hey you're good we're
smiling yeah isn't that weird because
teeth
are scary that's what you bite people
with they're pointy and sharp but yeah
with humans it's a good thing yeah oh
you were high I was so baked yeah forget
I brought it up dude those those
thoughts of when you're high did I
remember writing that like some of the
jokes on the right thing you read them
the next day and you're like this is
garbage I know but you think you're Bill
Hicks oh you think you're unreal I know
you think you're unreal I oh sorry
um so Soup To Nuts man I yeah
everybody's gotta go watch this your
last special how do you feel like it
helped because we talked about that I
think last time you were here yeah I did
an hour on Netflix nobody would buy it
so it was like a failure I just put it
on YouTube and suck it up take the loss
and uh I think that's some of my best
work
and then this this is a I kicked it up a
notch I went way darker I don't know if
you saw the whole thing but I got some
stuff I'm nervous about like some juice
stuff some black stuff some trans stuff
yeah no I I'm probably about 30 maybe 30
minutes in hey I appreciate it yeah more
than my parents I think anybody only
watches so much usually but I'll watch
the second half I was thinking maybe if
I get a date or something I'll sit and
watch it oh that's not bad yeah you'd be
like I know that guy yeah dude I know
that guy man people love him yeah I know
um blow me do you feel like it's gotten
uh how do you feel like success has
helped your personality or helped you
like do you feel sometimes like
you know because I know as Comics like
we want people to like us you know oh
yeah I know like we're desperate for it
I mean it's why that thing like we can't
have things be quiet sometimes because
the silence is scary for some reason you
know
um you know I've always thought that I
like to I liked I know when I was young
to make people laugh because I knew if
they were laughing that they couldn't
hate me at the same time right 100 I
feel the same way yeah and yeah I can
imagine most comedians probably do so I
wonder if some of that starts to
dissipate as we get
more success do you think I thought it
would but I think it's in the wiring
it's like baked in the cement is dry so
it's just always going to be that way
you you can get a little better but at
the core you're still the same dweeb
yeah you know it sucks it you almost
think you're you're gonna get some
Netflix special and you'll feel better
yeah it's still that's like I always say
people like I'm going to Hawaii I gotta
take the edge off and I'm like but
you're still gonna have your head in
Hawaii yeah you're gonna be on the beach
going what's up with the black people
not swimming yeah yeah how do I come on
a shark yeah yeah you're always gonna be
what's up with sharks teeth when I show
my teeth you know whatever that's still
gonna happen in Honolulu
that's why drugs are popular yeah and uh
alcohol
yeah man is it um does it feel like you
got a party on those bird tours you can
just do whatever you know because
sometimes I want to go but I just
sometimes I feel like since I'm not the
guy that can party that I'm like kind of
like
I don't want to be like people think I'm
like the [__] dad or like the
no there's a lot of positive uncle or
anything well we're we all know you're
closeted but you know you gotta have the
uh the alone time we're all introverts
deep down and there's only so much time
you can beat cracking jokes chugging
booze and all that so you got to have
your down time or you're gonna [__]
you're gonna Greg Giraldo yeah I was
just talking about him with someone oh
Jim Gaffigan oh nice yep and he's got a
special both you guys have specials
coming out this week what is that his
38th you know it's his 10th oh my Lord
that's insanity
that's very impressive it's unreal do
you think though that at some point
there's value into not putting out a
special and like like Bobby Lee right
has notoriously he's had some of this
like the same material for a long time
right and he makes up and he has new
stuff and and look I've done a lot of
the same stuff over the years I like you
know
um
but there's some every time I see Bobby
I lie he's so funny unbelievable but he
can't put that on that down on wax
because
you can't show your dick a different way
right in a new special right you know
maybe paints it black or something I
don't know but that's his big thing
yeah it's so
um
yeah it's like can you but that was the
kind of the cool thing back in the day
it was like you had to go see them yeah
that is pretty cool that's gone now but
is it though is it still like if you
don't put stuff out then people have to
come see you that's true I guess you're
right but my my thing is
a lot of it gets online somehow or you
put a clip up and so they go I'd love to
see this guy but I want to see new [__]
yeah like Jay Leno or whoever these old
guys could just do that that same act
forever and they were fine yeah I went
and saw
um Bob Newhart
wow love the new heart I think can you
bring a picture of him up I think he's a
legend Bob Newark yeah I went and seen
him dude and he was I think probably 80
something maybe 90. yeah and he was
doing jokes wow he looks like that lady
off of
um Ozarks a little oh yeah good call
with the heroin field yeah yeah yeah she
was [__] the young hillbilly kid yeah
I mean he looks like he took a strong
hit off some Poppy and never came back
he looks like the guy in the movie who's
just seeing the ghost yeah and he
freezes and turns old
I gotta ask you so you you're you're
doing very well I see these venues I
follow you on Instagram these venues are
huge yeah been pretty crazy I think do
you like because I like the love where
I'm at I'm scared of Fame and all that
[__] not saying I'm famous but like I
would never want to be that famous not
like you but like some of these guys
like Bert Chrysler is so huge oh like
yeah that seems almost scary to me yeah
I just feel like that's when uh people
start looking at you with a microscope
well I think you definitely your
anonymity starts to get lost I mean what
happened with me was a lot of tick
people took all my stuff and put it on
made it on Tick Tock ah the Andrew Tate
and so that took it to like a different
place it wasn't in my management you
know it was like um I mean there's
things people come up and ask me about
tell me they're so excited I've never
even remember I've never seen the clip I
don't even know oh yeah
um so that I think kind of took things
to a different level it's definitely
been kind of uh
like it's kind of a I don't want to say
that it's a bummer but one of the
tougher things about getting popularity
is you spend a lot of your time
defending yourself yes like hiding
myself yes when I get off the plane
today I go and kind of stand like in a
space away from where I know people
won't be
um you know just like little things like
that where you're just monitoring
um
how visible you are I don't know if that
sounds egotistical though no I get it
because sometimes just not ready to chat
oh it's some of the end you've and
you've had that you've and you've
already met a lot of people for the day
so sometimes it's like I'll be like if
I've already met 20 people today I can't
I'm my brain needs time to think about
stuff I need to do stuff in my own life
you know I have to take care of myself
and make sure I'm fed and whatever you
can't spend all your time meeting people
right yeah and part of you would like to
there's that part of you that's
desperate for people to like you of
course it's a catch 28 you know you want
them to like you then when they do
you're like all right but now you got to
give me space yeah so we are kind of
dicks in that way but let me just say
this you ever meet Theo out in the wild
say hello great stuff I love your pod
and then you gotta move on because the
worst part is that awkward [__] where
they're like now what and you're like no
we got I don't know you though yeah you
said your thing I got nothing on you I
don't know your mom or your where you
live or whatever if you were a Cub Scout
you know so that's always get in get out
the lingering is tough dude and that
goes for anything in life man one of my
friends told me one time he said be good
and be gone that's what he said oh I
like that and that had always had a lot
of value to me my friend will Kirby said
that he's a uh board certified
dermatologist hey and uh yeah he's doing
good the guy he's probably 50 looks like
he's
44 but spf'd to the gills dude oh yeah
you know gotta moisturize oh he's
[__] he's so Supple dude he's slick
oh he oh good for him he's so [__]
Supple
um
but yeah he said that to me and I always
thought that that was pretty interesting
because yeah you don't want to get stuck
into space with anybody and it could be
business it can be with women yes you
know especially anything you're kind of
like approaching new
if you get stuck in that extra space
where you don't have much prepared or
you don't know what you're going to do
then that's kind of
you know it's not the best right right
that's not a good answer for that but
it's just yeah you want to be good and
be going put in yourself because you
feel better than two you're like man
that was cool it was a good interaction
yeah perfect the best is like a guy on a
bike who just goes like gang gang yeah
yeah all right now that was perfect yeah
I got the recognition and no Chit Chat
and then he stands up and looks back and
says it yeah I think he has assless
chaps on him you're like whoa yeah pride
month well the worst is when you go oh
thank you and they go whoop they pull
that you and you're like oh nothing you
yeah I thought we were done yeah yeah
but again very nice I sound like a [__]
I'm like hey you [__] with the
hellos and the praise no I mean and it's
I think sometimes it's just what your
own day is like I'll tell people now
like hey man I'm just having a tough day
or you know I'll just be honest about
what's going on yeah let's put the
burden on them now so now they want to
leave yeah you know what if you just
start unloading your [__] like hey man I
can't get it up and I'm so glad we're
here to talk and he's like ah now I
gotta go
that's a good move
I think one of the things though too is
like
um
like on my pie like on on my podcast we
talk a lot about there's a lot of like
people that struggle with stuff so oh
yeah we go so sometimes it's like I can
tell like if somebody's struggling
sometimes like I want to be in that
moment and like some stuff you want to
share you want to hear what people have
going on
um but then some people have just seen
clips and they're just like uh you know
they're just
they don't know anything more so
sometimes if it's like a podcast fan
who's into your pod yeah then that can
be a little bit different you know
that's a little different yeah because
they know we're weird right and they're
probably weird too because that's the
thing right it's like dude you we were
probably the same type of weird because
we uh so you know like a lot of people
it's like oh I probably would have a
conversation with them if I just met
them regularly so true but you ever get
the guy like I read my DMs because I'm a
psycho and I'll get the guy like hey I
see you're coming to Nashville
I got a cabin if you want to come by
I'll I'll massage you and I'll cook and
you're like wait why would I do that
he's like I got knives and a and a snake
you're like what yeah yeah and someone
yeah we can get we have a family
graveyard in the back and you're like
I'm not doing that yeah you know the
guy's like we can make a soup we have a
great homemade soup here oh God some guy
wrote texted me the other day and he
goes
um
I'm gonna
I wanna suck your
that's what he said oh hey nice
what was that Rogan
wow
but see that's that's kind of what's fun
about being a guy is like if that was a
woman like I'm gonna suck your [__]
[__] yeah she's like it's hard being a
woman but with us we're like look at
this guy how funny my uncle well women
women
or women have gotten so vulgar in the DM
oh yeah it's a new world for the for the
clam yeah they're like let me come uh
let me come drop this split on you
they'll say crazy stuff huh I love it I
mean I'm married now but those were the
fun days and I would always write back
hey be good and be gone you know that's
it quick and Quicken out I had a girl
one time send me a damage with some huge
breasts oh yeah god dude you could see
like her yeah her breasts they even had
like a sunrise and Suns there was like
it was an eclipse oh they had yeah dude
yeah she wasn't a flat earther oh no she
believed in the truth you know she
believed in science man
she's too big though she just came she
we just got together in the lobby of the
hotel and played cards and that was kind
of cool come on what is that's weird but
it was nice though really there was some
kind of like old school and romantic
about it you know we played that game
speed have you ever played that I don't
know speed I've done speed I don't know
the game what's the game yeah it's it's
almost like being on the speed but
you're you're just doing it with the
cards and you're fine you can go to
sleep after oh yeah no hangover no crash
oh easy nice we had a nice time yeah
that's why I like shrooms oh just the
best drug I don't know if you ever did
them oh yeah dude it's a no hangover
they last about five hours it's kind of
natural yeah fun you can go into the
bathroom by yourself at least twice and
be like um yeah that's right that's
right but don't get a look in the mirror
because oh you're ugly yeah in that
mirror like oh how come people are
talking to me I'm a ghoul
dude the show got canceled on Friday so
we went out to the parking lot and we're
just meeting people that were showing up
yeah
and they had like five dudes that had
come they'd taken a bunch of shrooms to
come to the show oh man and you can see
their faces were all kind of shiny yes
that shroom glow yeah yeah you get that
shroom Club yeah which is beautiful it
looked like a happy child they look like
Angels yeah they're floating God could
you imagine being RFK Junior and having
taking shrooms and hearing your own
voice oh I think I was the devil dude he
could win he could win he's he's the
he's the opposite of Biden he's ripped
he has his own views uh I think he's a
bit of a kook and in some some areas
he's definitely on the fringes uh but he
wants to bring back the middle class he
wants to stop the war he's got some good
stuff yeah and he's able to say what he
think he's able to like share what he
thinks I think you believe he believes
what he believes right yes I don't think
any of it seems like he is saying it for
some and you here's the thing too you
know he is those are his police because
nobody's [__] believed him yeah and
they're pushing back like you [__]
weirdo yeah you crank they call him a
crank whatever that is yeah yeah they're
definitely calling them names from the
past yeah are you Charlotte and Gobbledy
good carpetbagger
you muckraker
yeah they're calling him stuff from the
past bro I know I know yeah oh the
internet and the paper are very mean
like it's an old man who's ripped trying
to trying to do his thing trying to save
the country yeah I've known him just
he's always been a stand-up dude he's
somebody that I would go to for
suggestion he's somebody that um I've
always really trusted just as a person
it's crazy to like know a person and
then be like oh they're going that's
crazy yeah yeah heroin guy yeah uh yeah
which makes me like it more oh dude well
that's the thing he's handicapped right
he's done heroin he's ripped yeah and
he's yeah he's ripped without the
heroine yeah and he's obvious he
obviously knows Larry David which to me
in my book that scores a few points yeah
that's a great Point huh I love that
yeah but the fact that he's speaking
that nobody believes so that's when you
know he's I mean the guy who's been on
his own yes so you know those are his
views you know he doesn't have any
lobbyists in his pocket yeah he doesn't
sound like any politics every politician
is kind of a puppet you know for the for
the man or whoever it is and he has his
own things and he had a great line
somebody goes uh you know Trump actually
likes you what do you think about that
and he was like I think it's cool and
they're like what but it's Trump but
he's like I know but we got to stop
fighting we gotta stop having this left
and right [__] let's just be Americans
and I'm like I I needed to hear that I
hate this division
podcast
thanks to Babel I know what that means
do you
well recently I've been learning to
speak Espanol
Spanish with Babel and you can too
because with Babel you can start
speaking a new language in just three
weeks that's it Babel offers it
tresemmanas you know what I'm saying the
best way to learn a language is through
immersion living where the language is
spoken natively and using it every day
one in five Americans have learned a new
language on their bucket list if that's
you check it off the list this summer
with Babel
because with Babel you start speaking a
new language in just three weeks that's
beautiful wow
science says our ability to learn new
languages Peaks when we're children
but since you can't go back to being a
six-year-old Babel is the next best
option here's a special limited time
deal for our listeners
let's get you started right now get 55
percent off your Babel subscription but
only for our listeners at
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash Theo get 55 off at
babel.com Theo spelled
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash Theo rules and
restrictions apply
yeah me too man I hate that like I go to
the UFC fights and Trump will be there
right and I feel like
um
that people are gonna judge me for it of
course for associating with them or like
like I would never judge any of my
friends if they associate it with
anybody I don't think you know here's a
picture right here I got asked to take
this picture whoa
and his camera wasn't
is Herb Dean yeah I couldn't eat that
well you really got the lean going huh I
try my best dude
holy [__] I'm surprised you could hold
up well if that somebody's phone I don't
know whose voice had like bacon grease
or something so any button I pray it
wasn't it was the ah the grease was so
thick well the gr it was kept taking the
hit of the grease so it was like if I
pressed a button it wasn't like saying
okay I'll accept that button all right
you got some dirty Italians from
definitely uh but how cool I was on the
bus with Bert watching this and I was
like there's Gillis there's David Spade
there's Theo there's uh Johnny Knoxville
yeah so cool I mean huge Spade in
Knoxville what that's the movie I want
to see and Spades become one of my he's
probably my best he's probably probably
my best friend in Hollywood these days
for sure oh did you ever think watching
Tommy Boy that you'd be hanging out with
that little twink dude not intense I
thought dude I remember when I first saw
Joe Dirt I thought it was real right I
thought that they had left
this kid at the Grand Canyon oh come on
yeah really I'm really believing that
when I was a child and [__] broke my
heart you thought it was a documentary a
really I guess I did and I don't
remember why I did but I just did you
know but um yeah so that anyway that's
just wild because then you're also there
with Spade which kind of gives you carte
blanche with like other celebrities and
stuff so he meets somebody I'm like hey
I'm right here yeah you know what's
Knoxville like Knoxville is kind of like
he seems kind of serious a lot of times
really yeah well his dick doesn't work
he'll probably make it a little more
serious oh dude well I probably good
thing we're I'm glad we're sitting near
each other and nobody's nobody's getting
[__]
yeah and if a lady shows up you got dibs
what's he gonna do go down on her for an
hour I don't know I'd probably be right
there next to him dude
dude my 20s I couldn't even get an
erection my 20s I had so much anxiety
right and that's [__] up with all
these kids now they got the Bluetooth
the Cialis all that stuff I'm like man
back in my day yeah you had to think of
something real in the bathroom and get
chubbed up and then run into the room oh
I remember trying to squeeze my butt
cheeks hoping to push the blood to the
front
remember squiding as hard as I [__]
could oh it's the word and your brain is
going in so many directions you're like
please please get hard she's right here
yeah oh it was so embarrassing that you
have the no it's not you it's me I'm in
my head and she's like you think I'm
ugly
I know you know I have picked I'll draw
I'll draw a picture of some vulva right
now for you with my eyes closed you know
I'm not gay and the saddest part dude I
I would notice my brain
because I would get in those instances
you know and I would feel so [__]
defeated and I didn't know it was
because I had so much anxiety around
women I just thought there was something
wrong with me I didn't know that it was
you know my mother didn't look at me for
14 years so I didn't have any connection
to how to if I if a one like yeah well
she saw that big hog of years
it's too awkward
but yeah that's yeah she saw that front
end loader dude yeah damn unless I'm
moving steam it in the yard
I'm not [__] with this baby he's
using your dick as the tar mom and
flattening it out with the it's a boy
it's a girl it's a dick yeah
oh but I I have a weird thing where I
couldn't get it up if I liked the girl
oh if I didn't like her I was a porn
star yeah I think there's a term for
that Benson if you want to give that a
goog yeah let's look that up
um but so I remember uh my brain would
start to say okay you need to have an
excuse now right but it would be like 5
a.m sometimes
I know and I would always say I'm part
of a swim team I remember and that we
have early practice damn that's good
swim too because no one lies about a
swim team right people would be like
that's who would say that yeah it's too
too specific but sometimes they're like
you're 28 years old right right you're
not even in college you know yeah yeah
that's when team are you on right
yeah
it the the things the place your brain
will go to get you out of that situation
and I'm like you don't support the mid
city fins
what if you yell some [__] you know I
can leave or sometimes I would say I
have to go and let my dog out oh yeah
that's good
but I don't know most guys would [__]
her and then get the dog yeah I feel
like but then there's a little bit like
oh this guy's a pet lover this guy's a
good guy that's true that's true but
women don't have to worry about I don't
know a lot of women who are like ah I
just can't get wet yeah like Jim Jeffrey
said that great bit where if I can't get
up it's my problem if you can't get wet
it's my problem Oh and I was like that's
kind of true
also don't turn a lady down in the
throes of passion she will hit you with
a frying pan oh they get it's so yeah it
really debilitates they really feel
affected by it oh yeah oh yeah yeah
sometimes I feel like I should go back
through my 20s and just make do like an
apology tour
go to cities where some of these women
live bring them in their current husband
up on stage
I had that in uh Phoenix I hooked up
with some comedy club waitress 10 years
ago yeah and I did the theater a year
ago and she came out with her husband
and it was awkward he was like I know
everything I'm cool with it man but he's
shaking your hand real tight and giving
you like a weird aggressive hug he said
he knew everything yeah he was like ah
she told me everything but hey it's all
good you come here you big galoot he's
nugging me and I'm like this is weird he
doesn't like this
God that is weird huh yeah and this girl
had a Nutella fetish so she would make
me put my dick in Nutella oh yeah
European yeah hazelnuts
I gave her the hazelnut yay but yeah two
pumps
oh dude that's interesting yeah I'm
trying to think of some good
um
yeah dude it was oh that [__] was
traumatic for me oh the worst not to
keep harping on it but that was tough
man but that ain't yeah it was just it
was so much anxiety being around or what
like oh yeah you know and then it starts
to dissipate it shows how powerful
you'll burnt your brain is because like
she would a girl would leave after I
couldn't get it up and I was so bummed
out and I put porn on and I'm hard in
two seconds it's all mental you just
gotta get a your brain's like a horse
you gotta learn how to control it or
else it'll just keep Galloping into a
bad place yeah into a place with no
boners
yeah it's tough but like I took
finasteride you know what that is oh
yeah I'm on it right now oh yeah me too
so I would take that and everybody's
like it's gonna kill your boners man
you'll have hair but you won't be able
to get hard and I'm like oh that can't
be true and I bought into it and so I
would hook up with girls and I couldn't
get up put it up but it was all in my
head literally yeah it's a hair yeah
but I never had a problem but then I had
to sit down with myself and go this is
all in your head you're [__] crazy
and I I got back to it yeah well I take
the blue shoes man I like them oh really
and what I like is you can have a
nibblable amount you know I can eat you
know how's the evening going how much
are you in love with this girl you've
been seeing or something and you can try
to take it you know and so you know that
is nice to be able to have a niblical
amount that is nice because the viagras
Dude I remember when I was in my 20s I
remember
I would go I went and lit you couldn't
just get by when they first came out you
were like damn bro old people are
[__] I remember yeah one time this
black dude came up to me is like hey bro
bro
old people are [__] you know I heard
those old folks homes are just orgies
and then he robbed a guy and I was like
whoa dude this is that's not even funny
dude never said that but um but so I
remember I went and lived a buddy of
mine his dad was getting a prescription
so I went and lived with him he was my
roommate so I could wow chirp off his
Viagra wow just that's the only reason I
mean I you know I like the guy as well
sure but the prescription helped it was
hard it was like plutonium back in the
day it was expensive it was hard to get
it was 60 bucks a pill yeah that's right
because they know you need to get laid
Yeah it's like that aids guy who jacked
up the Prize Martin shkreli oh yeah that
that [__] uh that Chooch yeah dude
slime ball oh he was that T-cell Hitler
T Cell Hitler okay piece of [__] I know
I know he's just walking around he's
free now yeah he's out he's doing
podcasts uh-uh he just did Legion of
skanks they got him no way guys pull it
up there Benjo
what was his name
something like that Legion of skanks I
think Gillis was on it as well
I think Gillis called him out even
but yeah that guy really uh yeah there
he is see what the the doofus hair he's
got the Hitler here too he's got the
swoop down one Martin's uh skrel
I can't believe they had him on I know
I mean he's an interesting kid let's see
him there he is wow he looks like a 10
year old
he looks like all of the West Memphis
Three
I just mushed into one yeah he kind of
looks like uh the kid from Toy Story
what a great group it's a fun pod it is
fun huh and skank Fest is also fun I
don't know if you've ever been to that I
haven't been they invited me one uh
Lewis has invited me two times the
weekends have just been
you know it's tough when you're all set
when you're touring of course of course
and the one weekend you have off it's
like you want to have it off yeah yeah
and that you can't have that all like
you're going all in on that it's Blues
it's crazy fans it's parties yeah
um
what else were we talking about boners
oh yeah but I remember living with that
guy but then the problem with the
viagras was you'd start taking them and
here was the problem your face would get
so red yeah and I remember I couldn't
bend my arms on someone when I first
started taking it even your arms were
boners you would oh yeah yeah wow damn
because that [__] is strong oh yeah I
felt like a cricket judge you know
you're like the guy at the uh the
airport yeah that's all you can move
yeah it was that [__] is strong I would
I took a half if I needed it oh yeah
well I would start getting nibblable
chunks but then even then I still had
problems really yup it was just because
it was still so in my head well here's a
question let me I wonder if I gave you a
Viagra but it wasn't real I bet if you
ate it you'd still be able to get a
boner easier than if you didn't just
because of the mental yeah you know yeah
I bet you're right like sometimes when
I'm really hungover I drink a cup of
coffee and I feel better sometimes if I
smell coffee I feel better because your
brain's like oh it's about to come in
just the smell of it so no caffeine has
hit me but just smelling it my brain
goes up we're good
pretty wild
yeah I think it's I think we don't even
know the powers of our brain and I think
the direction we're headed as a society
I don't know if we're
we're not that's not the thing we're
trying to learn now we're trying to
learn the we're so addicted the other
way it's like so true I mean we are
addicted to our phones we are addicted
to that next thing we are addicted to
vaping to Sugar it's almost like
I don't know sometimes it feels like the
the puppeteers if you will oh yeah the
people that big sugar yep big Tech you
know big Pharma yeah big Pharma he was
on The Sopranos oh yeah big puss yeah oh
bring him up his birthday's today shut
up bring him up what the hell is a
Mercury in retrograde we're connecting
here where periods are synced bring him
up yeah we should be on a volleyball
team
bring him up dude you know why it's
because it's WNBA All-Star oh boy the
spotting is must be crazy yeah
oh the spot up the spot Shooters out
there are [__] nuts
um just bring up big [__] birthday on
Twitter
areas
is it 77th birthday today
well a day ago or a day ago still scroll
a little yeah that's awesome dude
I I saw this because somebody keeps
scrolling uh somebody put
um they accidentally put Joey Diaz's
picture
one fat Italian for another Vincent
Pastore oh wait actually he's Cuban
sorry yeah uh
[__] sucker god dude what a wanna I mean
how do you find a guy like him yeah one
of a kind one in a mill I hope he's all
right yeah you ever taken one of those
Edibles he has
no we did shrooms on his show Once I
don't think I took an edible over there
they don't do it they're called like
stars of death stars of death hey Lee
you just feel you remember when Elon
Musk sent a convertible into space
that's how I felt when I took one I was
in space floating alone
brutal hated it well there's still that
famous episode where Owen Benjamin
couldn't it he he couldn't he went too
deep damn it's like a mental Viagra
because you're like you know when they
say if you're hard for four hours call
the police or whatever this your brain
is so high you feel like you'll never
get back to normal yes scares the [__]
out of me that is the that's the exact
dude that's the perfect statement that's
the that's the scariest part about some
of the drugs is that you're not going to
get back to normal yes it's that Alice
in Wonderland [__] where you're like I
guess I'm here now this is my life oh
the worst feeling yeah how will I ever
make a sandwich again oh my God forget
about it yeah God that was Unreal I know
um I don't love weed
yeah you know I never could admit but
then here's one thing that I noticed
after a while weed a certain type of
weed would make me be able to
um
do boners oh wow because it just it like
trumped whatever little part of my brain
was and I could do boners whoa oh that's
interesting oh I remember even texting
my mother when I when it first and I
said Mom because I told her over the
years you know about this you know I
have this problem and really bro it was
traumatic man it is pretty traumatic and
then you're in relationships and I
couldn't have sex with my girlfriend
oh man this is horrible can marijuana
save your sex life
um a growing number of doctors are
prescribing THC for everything from
erectile dysfunction to difficulty
orgasms look at that you were ahead of
your time we've known for a while at
least anecdotally that cannabis can
enhance the sexual experiences of women
now I've also noticed it'll make your
wife feel like a new woman you've never
met
when you're high when you're high
totally totally like oh these tits are
new these shoulders are new yeah yeah
but a recent survey of medical cannabis
users conducted by hello MD a
telemedicine let's scroll down
platform found that men and women had
seen a boost in their sex life
how do you like that see but I'm high
I'm not horny
really I'm just in my head too much I'm
thinking about you know sofas and
cookies and but is that an Indica though
I wonder if it's a the wrong strand
maybe I don't know my strands that will
yeah indica's in the couch
and then sativa is like the energetic
one oh I think it's Vice Versa oh is
that right okay Ben what is it yeah it's
they say the into couch thing so it's
basically indica's kind of mellow and
the other one will kind of give you an
energy but it really doesn't matter at
this game well I've never then I've been
doing it all along for a long time dude
you're smoking something getting boner
yeah but that was good man when I got
those boners dude it was fun that's a
great feeling you got married oh you're
off the market I'm off the market uh
happily married got a great lady and uh
where we're gonna maybe have some
Rugrats do the whole thing are you guys
doing embryo um are you guys gonna
Outsource it now nah we're gonna she's
young enough so I think we're gonna just
try to shoot loads fill up that yum
tunnel huh there she is hey there's the
lady oh wow dude bro was that scary for
you was it scary to commit to being
married of course terrifying I still
wake up every day scared oh wow she's
hot huh oh hey thanks I mean I'm not
looking at her but she seems hot she's
got a ample bosom great girl funny she's
funny yeah really funny I I I can't she
says horrible [__] around the house like
if anybody if Alexa was just like I've
been listening the whole thing I'm gonna
tell everybody
we'd all go to jail yeah but I like that
you know you know you hang out with a
girl and you say some offensive joke and
she's like okay yeah like all right we
could never hang out yeah she's the
opposite she's a psycho was that one of
the first like is that that's definitely
a thing you have to have a woman who's
funny or gets at least also who gets
jokes gets it that's even more important
she's got a great laugh I think you love
a lady with a laugh
yeah dude I used to think
yeah if I could have got my mother to
laugh at me then I don't know if I ever
would have done any of it no you'd be
saying you'd have no mullet you'd be
working at you know uh Pinkberry yeah
I'd be a manager yeah you just have a
normal life oh I'd have so yeah I'd have
been a local attorney you would have
been too oh really I think in Louisiana
ah dude declare my client did not rape
that woman they're always sweating too
like there's no AC in the South yeah
yeah dude
even if they are we'd have been wearing
sear bro from New Orleans we would have
been wearing seersucker suits oh yeah
we'd have been eating fried shrimp every
day yeah mint juleps oh yeah and begging
some judge yep to give our client some
leniency and probably some ambulance
Chaser fraud oh remember Morris Bart oh
yeah one call that's all I'm on your
side yeah remember chip Four Stall yeah
[Music]
takes care of it all dude every town my
uh the family that I went to live with
the dad worked for chip Forstall so I
got to go meet him whoa that was big he
was a celeb he was a big shot in
Louisiana Morris Bart chip for Stahl
morgus the presenter oh [__] how about a
18 25 too late whoa you knew that one
out nah was it Covington Covington would
you do that yeah dude that was good man
no one knows what the hell we're talking
about except for like three people yeah
they were just small like uh everybody
has their local like attorneys or
um grocery store yeah the Billboards you
see yeah yeah Louisiana had theirs and
those were some of the biggest ones
around the area yeah and you know what's
fun is when you do the road you just
flip through the hotel TV and some Like
Crazy Carl's fireworks Sunday come on
down half off ah it's wheelchair
Wednesday
crazy cars we've got the ramps out right
right I love them because it feels homey
you feel like oh this is a little
Community here well it's another thing
that we've lost by everything just being
so like uh like when Sirius bought out
all the radio stations when everything
just got so big it's like the value of
your hometown or whatever unless you
really care there's not as many like
little things that bring that have that
bring people together like in a common
space you know 100 those old Auto guys
like they were selling car used car guys
were great I see I see let it have it
let her have it that was the guy by us
dude yeah that was like it was a
furniture store well there's that famous
racist Furniture ad that goes on you
know there's like bring up racist
furniture store
's Furniture is a funny horror movie you
sit out in a chair and you're like I
hate Jews like it makes you racist
bro yeah yeah it's like it's like uh
that hat on uh Harry Potter oh yeah
we're in the courtroom like he had the
Hat on sir he was laid on the races
couch and he loves Asians
oh man
what was I thinking about what were you
talking about uh well let's see we're
talking about boners uh racist Furniture
uh
special
uh oh yeah these these killer whales are
running a muck
yeah well they killed a bunch of them at
this I saw this there was a cruise ship
pulling in a port where was this at what
a lot of times on cruise liners people
go out and and witness when the ship
comes into Port it's like a big moment
and people out there with their kids and
like Hey we're there we're in you know
Mexico we're in some made up Mexico like
plint to buyers yeah oh have you been to
plintabaya right every year it's like a
new place that never existed the year
before I know like Tulum yeah I heard
about Tulum and then one day that's all
I hear about is every white person's
going well we're summering in Tulum yeah
and we're also see it also seems kind of
sex trafficky doesn't it oh yeah there's
a lot of that going on in the Mexico it
seems like a lot of people just like a
lot of
um companies just flying chicks down
there and banging them yeah yeah and
more power to them you're making the
world a better not for them right a
cruise line has apologized to over 1 000
of his passengers after one of his ships
arrived at the port in the middle of a
whale hunt where dozens of the marine
mammals oh no we're being slaughtered
ah aren't they like a endangered yeah
why were they doing it can we go up and
see this
these poor whales man oh
incredibly disappointed that this hunt
occurred at the time that our ship was
in Port
well no wonder the orcas are pissed
yeah as has been
wailing still occurs in the Pharaoh
Islands today
um they've eaten pilot whale meat and
blubber since they first settled the
island so it's just part of their
tradition there
today as in times past the whale Drive
is a community activity open to all
damn see it's funny how Progressive
people love
brown people and immigrants but they
couldn't agree less with Progressive
people they're like we're gonna kill
animals there's a lot of gender roles
you know like these old school
tribe people or whatever you want to
call them
they're wild oh I see what you're saying
they're like we should give all this uh
Place back to the native inhabitants but
then the native inhabitants do stuff
like this which is something that
Progressive people would be totally
against exactly exactly like we make a
gay joke that's off color if you're like
you know
cancel them these guys are doing crazy
[__] yeah it's like hitting their women
and stuff well it's also like I used to
think about how like they would sell
like like it's fancy Spas they sell like
mud baths and stuff yeah but if you go
to but then they have countries
literally where kids are bathed in mud
and they're like we gotta help them
right right what do you mean that cost
300. that's hilarious you ever noticed
too about these Spas I did a gig in like
San Diego was like a rich area and oh
it's all these hot moms with little dogs
and they're Mercedes oh yeah and they go
into a spa all day and get massaged and
the Kiwi on the eye and all that and I'm
like
who needs a spot less than you these
roofers or landscape they need a spa day
they need a foot massage oh yeah dude
imagine have you seen that guy Vic
Blends that rolls up and cuts people's
hair no
like a drive-by cutting
it's too hard it's consensual yeah it's
consistent okay he pulls up
um what it's really neat guy he's on
Tick Tock and he pulls up and it's
mostly and he likes trimming up Brothers
right yeah really which is you know he
favors a black community I think I
haven't seen the ones I've seen it's all
young black men that he's trimming and
it's cool it's like you know it's a lot
of times it's a guy I saw one the other
day it was a garbage man right the guy's
in a truck work and he's like hey man
once you take a break for Tim you know
10 minutes let me tighten you up yeah so
he kind of like gets you know it's just
like it's like a it's pretty beautiful
what he does okay because right now it
feels like a trap yeah yeah
give me your kid for 20 minutes
yeah this video uh uh so he does that
and then oh [__] what are we talking
about uh
uh uh wait [__]
what was that
uh right before that though uh [__] I
just had it
oh Spa oh he had a spa
so who needs a spotless the mud bath
right wouldn't it be great if there was
a foot massager that did what Vic Blends
does oh yeah and he just rolls up on a
couple Brothers like hey boys y'all look
like y'all had a tough day out here I
don't know if the Bros would go for that
I would still be [__] wild that would
be wild hey let me touch up them low
nuggets homie you know what I'm saying
boy that's why I'm so jealous not to
change something I'm jealous of guys who
are in a feet yeah because they're
everywhere like we like tits but you
don't really get to see tits out in a
while but flip-flops open toe sandal
Barefoot women they're just there that's
true I never thought about that must be
nice yeah it must be nice to live just
in a smorgasbord like every everywhere
is a nudist colony yeah exactly
I mean and you could be one of those
guys like hey you're coming in here you
got to take your shoes off come to my
house I can't do that with a bra yeah
um and everybody wants a foot massage
yeah oh yeah that's the thing you roll
up like hey let me just let me touch
them hoofs baby yeah and they're like
please I had a hard day in these heels
oh dude if somebody came up right now a
strong I would have to be a woman though
for me to do it I don't want a man
pushing around in my feet and feeling me
like that no I think I'd prefer a man
really well I don't I got bad feet I got
a yellow toenail a bunion a canker a
hemorrhoid it's bad down why you have a
hemorrhoid well what do you got bunion
oh yeah that's like a foot hemorrhoid
it's like yeah if you're [__] out of
your foot you're not doing good
not there yet
um
yeah the roll-up foot massage that's
that's not bad
um what else was I thinking about dude
um so you guys are living in New York
though living in New York where you have
a spouse you feeling good about it
feeling good we're gonna buy a place in
Brooklyn like a bigger place with a yard
and stuff sorry so that'll be fun and uh
yeah you see my boy Louie around ever
Louis CK sure he's around I love him
yeah he's great god dude I don't know if
there's anybody funnier than him I mean
he's definitely one of the best of all
time
for sure just his bro like I'll talk to
him on the phone and I'm not trying to
like humble brag or anything I mean I
love he just and he I'm laughing so hard
yeah he loves you he really uh I listen
to that episode and he really blew you
which is rare for him
it was nice of him he and I've become
buddies oh that's great yeah it's again
like David Spade did you ever think oh I
can't even imagine I used to watch him
on Comedy Central when I was in college
yeah
it's crazy dude yeah that's what's great
about comedy is like if you're just some
Guitar Bar guitar guy you're never gonna
meet Mick Jagger yeah he's the top but
we can meet top comedian I've met
Seinfeld and all these guys oh yeah it's
not that weird
we're all Comics yeah there's less
pretension in comedy
oh that's interesting
yeah there's less pretension in it
um yeah one crazy thing uh so at the UFC
Shane Gillis had on Versace huh oh yeah
did he changed her that did not feel
like him he's always the black T-shirt
guy yeah
I was like wow somebody you know
yeah well you get you get out there with
the rogans and the UFC it
you start changing you know you get that
evil in you yeah something that happens
man you want to buy a tiger and and uh
buy like a little car yeah get a faced
hat yeah yeah Mike Tyson
who what can we do we most likely you
think to get a face tat
um well Delia got a neck that's as close
you can get yeah
face that's tough
um yeah who would it be yeah maybe Lewis
J oh yeah that's pretty good because he
like he's into fighting and stuff he's
in a jiu jitsu you know you know he's a
tough guy
um I don't think it would look bad on
him no it would work right it would work
I think Katt Williams could do something
oh yeah something nutty on the face
I can't decide what he would do he's my
number one podcast guest that I want to
have oh his feet wouldn't hit the floor
yeah he's so little he's cute oh he's
tiny but he's so [__] funny oh yeah I
always thought he should have done
comedian cars with coffee just those two
in a car together couldn't be more
different oh man that would have been
gold that have been so gold wow yeah he
does uh he does these Arenas my friend
used to open for him he's got stories
really yeah one time he was late
apparently and uh he gets paid in cash
in an arena that's you're making a lot
of money
you have to use two hands probably to
put that bag on his back that's expense
that's a lot of tons tons of cash but he
was late for the gig so he felt bad so
he said pay me now and he was throwing
the money out into the audience wow
crazy uh uh and he's only famous from uh
I guess he did some cop BT stuff but I
think he was just on a movie
well he did that comedy special in the
green oh yeah or purple jacket which one
was it he's had a couple but yeah he's
so funny
oh he does have a face tattoo oh I
called it oh he tattooed a goatee on
damn he could have just waited
yeah
I need to do that oh there he is right
there that was the one
whole Little Tink tank remember that
yeah Pimp Chronicles I thought it was so
good
I just seen him an open mic like how
does a guy like that start was he like
hey uh milk's weird yeah you know or did
he just come out of the gate that suit
that's a great point I couldn't even
imagine Katt Williams that like is going
to do his first comedy set Wild
well a lot of black guys are just built
that black people have some just
built-in funny black people have so much
fun joking and making fun of me it's
like there it's always like that like
the kids around the middle school table
like yeah on the table totally that
energy keeps forever in the black
community I feel like I know it's a lot
of energy and ball busty and they say
funny [__] like you gotta you gotta head
like a box cutter and you're like damn
how'd you think of that damn Larry got
that box cut up
I know and there's
a dance
it never ends like damn I was hoping
that box cutter they wouldn't catch on
damn Larry working for UPS with that
head that's one nice thing about growing
up in Louisiana we were exposed to a lot
of that that's a good point man and
there was always there you always wanted
to make black people laugh
if you could get them and also black a
lot of black guy when I was growing up
you know a lot of black guys were real
scary you know there was a lot of
violence so you had to fall you had to
be like I gotta make this guy [__]
wow oh yeah yeah definitely he doesn't
have a dad yeah Somebody's gotta [__]
bring some I have to at least bring like
yeah there was something about that man
yeah like if because you had to find
some way to communicate with bike it was
tough back then it was different it was
a little different it was definitely
different there was a clear tension
you know you would walk up and the
record would scratch yeah dude you felt
definitely uncomfortable yeah um
you think that tension will ever go away
in the world like the attention from
because there's a lot of there's also a
lot of like blood there's a lot people
always racism always gets blamed on
white people right sure I feel like
which is very exhausting because as a
modern day person you can't do anything
to go into the past yeah I know I know
it's tough and I get it I get the anger
yeah if I could go into the past like
you know 600 years ago or something and
work for the Coast Guard or whatever
sure you know I would have shut all that
stuff down yeah yeah what do you think
maybe but it was so normal then you
might have just gone with it it's like
being a Nazi I don't I don't know I
think I would have I don't think I would
have either just because I'm I want to
be liked so I don't care what you look
like yeah I'm still gonna tap dance for
you yeah that's a good point you know
but yeah that is tough uh but do you
think that uh and then I think the
hatred and stuff like that it just gets
stuck in D sometimes you get stuck in
DNA you know of course I think some of
that stuff takes so like if your
grandparents went through a ton of pain
or an unfair life then I think that gets
in the DNA and it takes generations for
it to pass through right yeah I agree
but we'll find any way to hate another
group it doesn't have to just be skin
color you like Rwanda what is that the
shoot twos and the Shiites and the
tootsies yeah they're both black but
they hate each other we'll always find a
way you know with the left and right
it's it's uh it's all you need now
yeah I wonder if that is
yeah you know I think a lot about that
is that just part of nature because
nature is that too you know a zoo if you
if you took the cages down in a zoo oh
yeah half those animals would
immediately kill the other half exactly
it's like jail they always go Aryan
Nation black guy Mexican guy yeah and if
you're Asian
you're getting [__] yeah dude oh
you're though you're a you're like a
little uh Christmas ham you're a little
Sitting Duck Sauce
oh that's good dude yeah it's just
tribal it's in the DNA we had to survive
like that for hundreds of years and
sometimes I wonder do we ever get to a
point where there isn't any of that or
is that just
you know like will that just always be
nature and this idea that one day
everything will be completely harmonious
well it's better now than it's ever been
yeah I think especially with young
people you see that definitely
definitely like you'll see young kids of
like different ethnicities and stuff
hanging out and it's totally chill yeah
I'm like holy you don't even realize
this guy's a [__]
he's got the Chopsticks and everything
like what are you kids doing yeah if you
want to be racist now you have to have a
chart you literally have to know math
like you have to be able to divide yes
and figure it out but now it's it used
to be racial divide or gay divide or men
women divide now it's oh you disagree
with my ideology or whatever yeah you're
no friend of mine yeah you know it's
it's all become opinion based now
instead of color based so we still have
hatred we just put it into a different
gutter
um
yeah it's just kind of you know that's
the thing being it being alive is just
interesting because you're like okay
well this kind of stuff always be there
I know I just think you can't get rid of
everything and it's all cyclical like I
saw this thing in the 70s where like
Battle of the Sexes men and women aren't
getting along and you're like oh it's
just like now we're not that different
yeah but you know you ever see a dog
about to take a nap and he circles the
rug three times then sits down oh yeah
you know what that is that's uh
Sundowners isn't it well what is that
oh a dog you know what it circles around
then it sits yeah it lays down yes yes
they're flattening the grass from the
wolf days this is in the DNA so that
[__] is imprinted yeah
so I'm just saying like we're always
gonna be tribal right yeah I think about
this like the other day I don't like
being in traffic that much right and if
it's on the interstate sometimes and
there's a hold up I'll go around the
side
sure right I'll just go I'm willing to
get up there and see the cop and he's
like hey you're going to jail that's
fine I'd rather go to jail than sit back
there yeah and wonder why somebody's
holding me up I'm with you
but then I realized the other day what
if if like 20 cars just said you know
what
[__] it we're not doing the rules
anymore yeah
how how far after that Tipping Point
does that you know like if one police
precinct gets taken over by a group of
[__]
um anarchists or whatever oh yeah it's
happened how like how like it the scale
enough to tip much before everything
goes into Anarchy oh dude it's so true
uh we had a hurricane in New York a
couple years ago and all the power went
out it took 20 minutes for it just to
become martial law you heard gunshot
glass breaking a woman you didn't know
what was going on it was Pitch Black in
the city with millions of people it
happened
20 minutes it went to full chaos yeah
like it's so fragile the line that we're
on of like organ like
it's basically lines in the road yes
they keep us in shape but it's real easy
to to drive over that line yeah and
that's what I realized I was like oh I
can just do this like of course I can
face some repercussions but if everybody
right now decided to do this then what
are the cops gonna do right if everybody
if yeah all it takes is enough people
saying [__] this right now at the same
time exactly well that's how Gay's got
marriage yeah there's just enough of
them got together like we're gonna break
[__] or [__] each other or [__] you in
the ass so you better let us get married
that's a good point once again yeah
that's a and that was the move gay dude
should have done like hey Governor we're
coming you're gonna somebody's [__]
you buddy like all right all right do
whatever you want yeah do what you want
yeah go to go to Claire's
um I'll make it happen man you're gonna
have Claire's you're gonna have this
neighborhood
man gaze will fix the neighborhood yeah
there's something special about gays huh
they really are they're magical people
because they can't reproduce but they
keep popping up yeah isn't that why yeah
they're not even worried like Jews are
like we gotta we gotta make more of us
you know we're going away but Gabe's
like we're we're gonna be all right yeah
yeah yes God's doing it for us somebody
is yeah well they had that you know
Kennedy was on Rogan talking about that
atrazine can you look that up where they
put some frogs in this chemical called
actress and they put it in the water
where the frogs lived and some of the
frogs are gender changed no way over
time and then he was saying that there's
a level and don't quote me uh maybe you
can quote me on this if you can bring it
up
um that there's a level of atrazine in
the water supply in some places oh [__]
so that could be part of the reason why
suddenly you have people whose gender
kind of seems like in the uh in the wind
whoa fascinating and scary
what do we got here if you expose frogs
to atrazine male frogs it changes their
sex and they can actually Bear young
they can lay eggs fertile eggs
transphobian yeah that's transphibians
dude whoa and is yeah find another
article on that see if we can see an
article we can it's the same CNN Alex
Jones got yelled at four for making that
frogs gay meme it's the exact same thing
oh it is yep but is there another
article if you go down anymore
um
oh yeah the herbicide atrazine is one of
the most commonly applied pesticides in
the world so so it's in a lot of uh
they're spraying it on crops as a result
atrazine is the most commonly detected
pesticide contaminant of ground surface
and drinking water atrazine is also a
potent endocrine disruptor that is
active at low ecologically relevant
concentrations previous studies showed
that atrazine adversely affects
amphibian larval development the present
study demonstrates that reproductive the
reproductive consequences of atrazine
exposure and adult amphibians uh were
both demasculinized
and completely feminized as adults ten
percent of the exposed genetic males
developed into functional females that
copulated with unexposed males and
produced viable eggs
wow scary stuff I mean that's is this
legitimate what site is this from this
has been a thing for a long time
actually okay
atrazine induces complete feminization
and chemical crash station in male
African clawed frogs dude and if you can
do that to an African you could easily
do it to a wife that's true yeah African
makes everything kicks it all up in an
African Killer Bees you're like oh [__]
yeah I'm not [__] with him yeah but
some local honeybee dude oh forget to
sodomize that thing yeah yeah
um but no African is you know it's tough
I mean Africans are made out of tough
they you know they have tougher head
they're tough they're [__] tough
tough people they're tough people
um and they have the hiss you know dude
I remember looking into an African
dude's eyes one time oh you could see
bro I feel like you could see a fire
like 30 000 years ago I believe it you
don't want to [__] with them like the
timeline you know yeah he was just
digging a diamond mine yeah four years
ago oh yeah now he's selling a person
Broadway
whereas you look into some you know you
looking at some honky's eyes over there
in Topeka you know it's somebody having
a muffin two weeks ago yeah exactly it's
a chick holding a small dog in there
yeah that's it with a yoga mat
um what topic were we just about to get
into uh wrap up I know you got a show oh
[__] I'm gonna jump on stage with you is
that okay please that'd be great I want
to see this new old bit Yeah okay dude
and I don't want you to have to work too
much tonight so oh yeah I'm on fumes but
[__] we're gonna have fun yeah I had to
get I mean I didn't sleep last night I
just went to the airport and um
and yeah I got a new uh like disguise
when I that I wear when I go through the
airport oh really yeah what do you well
I guess you can't give it away um
yeah I probably can but I'll I'll put a
picture in okay because I don't have the
the shades on me that I wear it's just a
full Clan Hood
just walking through an airport
credit card sign up for your credit
cards
um no there was something we were just
oh
do you think
um I gotta worry that I'm I don't want
to get roseanned here really well you I
just don't sometimes I worry though your
episodes getting clipped like crazy oh
yeah they they got
um yeah that was kind of crazy man but I
had a lot of people reach out and
support yeah and then Elon Musk shared
the episode that's insane which if he
can if they could find a way where you
could say post uh episode onto if if
they could just find a way to make a
player on there hmm
oh like a little like a screen a TV
thing right right because now you can
put a full episode but if they could
make it where you if you click on that
like you know Twitter has a little box
is your whatever you want to watch so
you're on your on your laptop you see
like this little okay this is here let
me I can click on it make it bigger yeah
if you clicked on something that had a
video in it right if it went if it
expanded into a bigger player like an
actual like okay you can navigate this
screen easier just for the videos things
that's like a streaming right if it's
yeah if just when you clicked on that it
expanded into a stream it into
immediately that square went into a like
morphed into a streaming platform of
sorts that's good then it would be
really fascinating because now you have
an avid player right yeah you can put
stuff in and they can move on the
timeline easier I think that's what
they're trying to get to I think that's
a great idea and the porn on Twitter is
wild that's another thing because it's
like yes you're trying to learn and then
you're jerking off yeah you got animal
attack and then anal yeah it's a lot
it's uh Colin Quinn always says
Twitter's like giving yourself
schizophrenia because it's just a
million opinions and ideas and hate and
anger and a sandwich coming at you at
once that's a lot of [__] yeah yeah it
is it's always it's like and I think
we're starting to realize that this
stuff is really bad for our brain oh 100
and it's defeating people it's like
people don't have their own ideas
anymore and I notice I I have to give my
brain I have to say I cannot look
through stuff you gotta do it because
that's the the war these days you want a
Vietnam these days the enemy is your
whatever's trying to take your attention
I know and they're so good at it they
got that algo Tick Tock I got twerking
Chinese women and [__] you're like how
can I turn this off yeah it's like Down
Syndrome guy who loves pro wrestling
you're like oh black people seeing magic
yeah you can't beat it yeah
yeah and it just one and right when you
almost get a little bit bored they flip
it to a new thing like what's this
so did you know historically
yeah I get a lot of this historical
video uh things too that come through
um and then the murder the crime report
Brian coburger they just found a glove
dude um
I was thinking about this man about like
with a lot of people that come out to
see Comedians and
um I noticed I have a tough time like do
you ever have a do you have a tough time
feeling proud of yourself do you think
of course yeah it's hard to absorb that
I'm working on it you gotta you gotta
sit and just tell yourself to be
grateful
we're being grateful I think but yeah
like I can feel grateful I think but I
think feeling proud of myself I'm
noticing because I notice a lot of times
people like me you should be proud of
yourself you know and it doesn't even
land anywhere with me like I hear them
and I believe them and I know that and
it's not like I don't want to but it's
almost like no it's like you never learn
that like there was never any knowledge
put into you of like this is how you
feel proud of yourself this is what
Pride feels you know like yeah I have
the same thing why do we have that I
don't know because one negative comment
I'll I'll sit on that for three weeks
yeah
yeah but the pride thing nothing
yeah why is it so hard why is it so hard
to feel because proud of yourself you're
saying somebody's saying hey uh you
should feel good about yourself for this
thing to me a lot of times if I start to
feel proud of myself it goes to Ego it's
like you should which you don't want
that either right right you and you
really don't you really want to try and
stay away from that so
yeah I don't know it's interesting I
wonder too if it's something that
and I'm not trying to have self-pity or
blame parents or anything but is it
something that you have to learn as a
kid like do because that's a weird thing
you wouldn't think to teach your kid
yeah but how do you teach being proud
you know like I have I get I don't get
Pride with comedy even though we should
look you've built an Empire you got your
big house with the studio and the
specials and money and all this
but then that does nothing for me and
then if I'm at a party and somebody goes
that's a good question I'm like oh oh I
had a good question oh totally I love
that but the comedy thing is hard to to
take in
yeah man and it's funny you know too
it's like and I have a yeah I have a
nice home here and it's nothing crazy
this is beautiful you know thank you
yeah it is but I it's it is nice right
I'm happy to have I it's funny I felt I
felt as ashamed to show my home
as I did to show my apartment that we
lived in when I was a kid just a
different kind of Shame like big
well like I I don't want people thinking
I don't want people seeing that I don't
have anything uh and then I don't want
people seeing that I do have something
yeah I totally get it
I know what you mean because you'll get
zinged either way yeah I can't figure
out what it is it's just like no matter
you don't want to stand out you want to
be in the middle we want to blend
if you're poor everybody's like look at
the poor loser and if you're originally
look at this [__] yeah and I think I
always hate I think I all rich people
when I was growing up was always the
Nemesis dude of course still is when
they found those submarine queefs they
were like oh these poor guys and they go
hey they're billionaires and they go ah
[__] them like wait what yeah I still
have people with feelings I never got
that rich hate
but it's 100 right in the movies it was
always the yeah the [__] rich guy
yeah and I don't think part of you never
changes I always hate the [__] rich
guy yeah yeah you know because I think
also I know I could easily the part of
me that's the poor guy will always is
always going to be there of course the
only things that are easier is just
knowing that my rent will be paid and
that I'm gonna have food but outside of
that it's like how do I
I wanna I wanna figure out better things
to do with earning money or with making
things fair in the world I think I don't
know but do you ever think if you had if
you started feeling proud you might work
less
like that non-pride is kind of
motivating you to chase it yeah
oh yeah there's something about like the
desire to want to do things that you're
so fortunate that that's in you yeah
yeah it's it's kind of a double-edged
sword because you're never happy with
your work
so you keep working right but if you
were happy with it you might just might
take a break yeah or slow down
yeah it's just interesting to think
about it I'm sure a lot of people deal
with that and so that's why I wanted to
think about that
um about how hard it is to accept Pride
so it makes you wonder is it good or is
it a good thing or a bad thing because
it sucks you can't accept it but it's
also keeping you a fire in your dick
yeah you know and you need that you need
people that have a fire like what if
guys like
um you know some of the greatest
creators of our time you know if
Einstein if
um
Mattel oh yeah if Tyson mm-hmm you know
um chicken or the boxer chicken okay
but if people just got or like uh after
his first nugget he's like I'm done
right and he never makes the meals yeah
you see it pays to be insecure yeah it
keeps you going yeah
there's some value in all of it
um Soup To Nuts that's your new special
oh yeah and do you plan a tour right
after how many people get these plans
does it matter to you what are you
thinking about I got a big theater tour
uh selling like hot cakes but hopefully
after the special it sells more we start
adding shows but again I need some new
[__] material you'll come if any of
you come up within [__] metamoro ah
thanks you're so funny man well trust
I'll try anything I'm throwing [__]
against the wall you'll see tonight it's
gonna be a [__] show yeah good good man
I'm happy to be over there thanks for
letting me jump on hey anytime
um Mark Norman we can people can check
out your tour online on your website
everything oh yeah markdormancomedy.com
yep and uh dude thanks for making time
dude and uh congrats on all your success
bro thank you and always a pleasure to
see you there fatty yeah I'm proud of
you man I'm proud of you a couple
Louisiana boys made good what half what
the hell I mean if you would have showed
us at an open mic I would have gone
these guys are going nowhere and then
here we are sitting on some racist
Furniture
yeah oh this thing is [__] I feel I'm
warming up dude yeah I better slur if I
can set the cooling in oh yeah
um all right Mark thank you brother
thank you praise Ella
foreign
[Music]